[Aplausos]
ayer esta parada en este mismo lugar
viene a practicar esta charla
y sin embargo me sentía y tenía una
constante sensación de que no me merecía
estar acá
y es que las mujeres nos enseñan y a
veces nos educan aquí no nos merecemos
triunfar
que no nos merecemos conciliar una vida
personal y profesional
qué nombre se mostrará un escenario como
éste
y hoy día para mostrarles que el
paradigma se puede romper
y que en mi vida yo lo rompí
hace 10 años empecé mi carrera
profesional y era una persona totalmente
distinta a lo que soy
este primer día gente a trabajar lo
único que pensaba era en un minuto
va a llegar un desarrollo laboral y un
minuto en mi carrera que voy a tener que
tocar techo porque voy a tener que ser
una familia y voy a tener que elegir
para mí lo que era invisible en ese
momento fue que una mujer en ese minuto
me dijera daniela se puede hacer las dos
cosas
y día
me siento emocionada y feliz de decir
que mi vida profesional es la mejor
aliada de mi vida personal
y que soy infinitamente feliz
saben cuántas mujeres en chile son
felices
el 65%
y si existían mujeres saben cuántas
pueden llegar a un cargo directivo menos
de 7
yo estoy dentro de estos dos números
y lo importante fue que nunca nadie me
dijo que podía llegar hasta el 2
hay un estudio de accenture a accenture
hace anualmente que se llama getting to
equal y habla de ciertos indicadores o
condiciones de las organizaciones que
permiten generar ambientes más diversos
yo me quedo con tres factores
principalmente y el primero es toda la
flexibilidad o acción total que una
organización puede tener el segundo en
el empoderamiento que para mí es igual
la confianza y el tercero el liderazgo
da
cuando voy a pensar que es este tema de
acción completa y la flexibilidad
este estudio habla que las
organizaciones que tienen políticas
procedimientos que promueven la
flexibilidad laboral tienen un 33 por
ciento de probabilidad de tener
ambientes más diversos y agilizar la
carrera de sus trabajadores
empresas que promueven todo lo que es
la ley y todo lo que es perdón la
maternidad y cuando uno va a tener un
bebé y solamente lea los beneficios a
las mujeres tienen menor probabilidad de
tener mujer en su organizaciones cuando
promueven el permiso posnatal para
hombres y mujeres
yo tengo la suerte de tener dos niños y
tengo la suerte también de hace dos años
de haberme parado millás y haber dicho
yo quiero trabajar flexiblemente nadie
me ofreció crearlo pero yo lo fui a
pedir hoy día voy todos los días a dejar
a vicente que tiene cinco y a la maría
que tiene cuatro al colegio y después me
voy a trotar y tengo horario diferido
trabajo de una manera flexible y lo
busqué así porque mi objetivo mi
compromiso mi responsabilidad no cambia
por encontrar la mejor manera de poder
trabajar en una empresa
el segundo factor es el empoderamiento y
es la confianza
las empresas que desarrollan y generan
más confianza en todos sus trabajadores
tiene una mayor probabilidad de tener
ambientes más diversos
y la confianza es aceptar a todos como
somos la libertad de expresarse de ser
como uno quiere ser de vestirse como
cada uno se quiere vestir de pensar de
lo como de la forma que cada uno quiere
de promover la expresión la creatividad
la innovación
voy a contar algo de un paso es un
tiempo en la organización que
actualmente trabajo al segundo año
mi jefe llego y me dijo daniela fuiste
promovía gerente
mi corazón latía rápido por dos motivos
el día antes me habían dicho que estaba
esperando mi primer hijo
y el segundo era porque decía como tan
rápido llegue hasta gente increíble
y mi cabeza me decía no te lo mereces
está esperando guau guau
no la idea de tu jefe
no tenemos es cliente
pasó un tiempo que empezó a crecer la
aguadita
con mis pies muy nerviosos elige estoy
esperando a vicente
y fue una gran lección me abrazo
y me dio la confianza de que estaba todo
bien
de que a pesar de que como mujeres
y positivamente tenemos otros ciclos
tenemos la misma igualdad de
oportunidades
y cuando yo logré entender que el
empoderamiento era en mi ciclo femenino
tener las mismas oportunidades se sentía
absolutamente libre libre de llegar a
donde yo quisiera
y a mí eso nunca me la da y me lo dijo
el tercer punto el líder aguda
y el liderazgo audaz habla de que las
mujeres desarrollamos a las mujeres
en empresas donde hay mujeres líderes
es más probable que el ambiente sea más
diverso y es más probable que hombres y
mujeres agilicen su carrera
y desde este último punto estoy para acá
porque quiere ser llamado
y quiero sacar la fuerza como mujer
invitarlos a que se sumen a esta fuerza
a que aumentemos es de 65 por ciento de
felicidad a que aumentemos de este 7 por
ciento de directiva
a que promovamos la confianza a que
promovamos la flexibilidad a quien
promovamos el liderazgo pero no desde el
año 10 de carrera a que lo enseñemos a
cada mujer que tengamos el frente
yo las invito a ser protagonistas de
esta fuerza para ser visibles
lo que para mí nunca fue invisible y
decirles que todo se puede yo nunca me
imaginé llegar a dónde estoy
y como una maestra me dijo lo imposible
solo está un poquito más allá muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]